when you think about entities that's out
there extraterrestrial do you think they
would naturally look something that even
is recognizable to us isn't his life or
can it would they be radically different
well how did we become intelligent
basically three things made us
intelligent one is our eye sight stereo
eyesight we have the eyes of a hunter
stereo emissions will be lock-in on
targets and and who is smarter predator
or prey predators are smarter than prey
they have their eyes at the front of
their face like lions tigers wild
rabbits have eyes to the side of their
face why is that hunters have to zero in
on the target they have to know how to
ambush they have to know how to hide
camouflage sneak up stealth to see that
takes a lot of intelligence rabbits all
they have to do is run so that's the
first criterion stereo eyesight of some
sort second is the thumb the opposable
thumb of some sort could be a claw or
tentacle so a hand-eye coordination
hand-eye coordination is the way we
manipulate the environment and then
three language because you know mama
bear never tells baby bear to avoid the
human hunter bears just learned by
themselves they never hand on
information from one generation to the
next so these are the three basic
ingredients of intelligence my site of
some sort an opposable thumb or tentacle
or claw of some sort and language now
ask yourself a simple question how many
animals have all three just us it's just
us I mean the primates they have a
language yeah they make it up to maybe
20 words but a baby learns a word-a-day
several words a day a baby learns and a
typical adult knows about almost 5000
words well the maximum number words that
you can teach a gorilla in any language
including their own language is about
twenty or so and so we see the
difference in intelligence so when we
meet aliens from out of space
chances are they will have been
descended from predators of some sort
they'll have some way to manipulate the
environment and communicate their
knowledge to the next generation that's
it folks so functionally that would have
that would be similar that would we
would be able to recognize them well not
necessarily because I think even with
Homo sapiens we are eventually going to
perhaps become part cybernetic and
genetically enhanced
already robots are getting smarter and
smarter
right now robots have the intelligence
of a cockroach but in the coming years
our robots will be as smart as a mouse
then maybe as smart as a rabbit if we're
lucky maybe as smart as a cat or a dog
and by the end of the century who knows
for sure our robots will be probably as
smart as a monkey now at that point of
course they could be dangerous
you see monkeys are self-aware they know
they are monkeys they may have a
different agenda than us while dogs dogs
are confused you see dogs think that we
are a dog that we're the top dog they're
the underdog that's why they whimper and
follow us and lick us all the time for
the top dog monkeys have no illusion at
all they know who we are not monkeys and
so I think that in the future we'll have
to put a chip in their brain to shut
them off once our robots have murderous
thoughts but that's in a hundred years
in 200 years the robots will be smart
enough to remove that failsafe chip in
their brain and then watch out at that
point I think rather than compete with
our robots we should merge with them we
should become part cybernetic so I think
when we beat alien life from outer space
they may be genetically and and
cybernetically enhanced
you